hi my name is markiplier and today I'm
gonna be telling you all about the
wonderful world of slime now slime is
all the rage these days
the kids love it they're making it in
their backyards in their basements all
by their lonesome and I wanted to share
with you my very own recipe for slime
all you'll need are a few simple
ingredients you can get in any
department store
you've got Elmer's glue shaving cream
the special ingredient borax and some
warm water now these ingredients
combined into a wonderful concoction
make the wondrous material slime and
it's as simple as this you start out
with some regular old glue pour that bad
boy into a bowl now if this is taking
too long and you're not getting enough
volume out of your squirt just pop the
lid off and pour that bad boy right in
that's a nice glob how about low for
Danny you're gonna need about this much
glue all right makes sense now once
you're done with the glue once you're
done with the glue then you move on to
the shaving cream now it needs to be
thick and foamy
the foam ear your cream additive the
more foamy the slime will be now you
just take it shake it up real good like
and blance you got yourself some slime
how about a little for Beavis chica come
here come on
okay good girl all right we got our two
ingredients here we just need to add a
little bit of what's called borax which
has a bonding agent coal boric acid once
you put that in there you don't need a
lot just enough to give it a nice
dusting and hopefully this doesn't
combust which would be amazing
ordinarily you would use a spoon for
this because this is going to be
extremely caustic to your hand
it's a these ingredients when they're
mixing together they're extremely acidic
so it's not recommended that you use
your hand and mix it that's really
coming together all right now that's a
good consistency right there very
malleable if your ratio is a little off
just feel free to add or remove as
necessary
now the last step in order to apiece the
Dark Gods is you need to take your knife
and the old knife will do even a kitchen
knife so long as it's sharp enough and
then just cut the center of your palm
and let that seep into the concoction
while you whisper the words of power
where tennen rishin wash
and then you have you saw some nice
foamy slimy substance look at it it's so
fun that's good stuff right there
alright so there you have it you have
some lovely slime for your whole family
to enjoy and we all get to enjoy three
years of peace before the Dark Gods
consume us all thanks again for watching
my name is ben markiplier and as always
bye-bye
[Music]
now you may be wondering how these
ingredients can combine together into
the exto plasmic nature of slime well
it's as simple as missing and the kids
are all about slime these days it's not
just about dabbing myself now you may be
asking yourself what is slime or is it
pronounced lamay no it's not [ __ ] hi
shut up okay now if you don't know about
slime or having watched Nickelodeon in
the past 20 years it's all the rave with
the kids these days they're making it
for themselves in their own backyards in
RVs on the middle of the desert